so 30 for you you decided okay you know
I'm gonna try it out and go to an open
mic yeah first of all Mike um the club
booked me that day and I got booked
twice the day but one was a bringer
they're trying to use me to yeah Wow
one person genuinely thought yeah I
think you're funny and let me help you
in you know he reminds me of Peter
you're the gay Peter Peter can yeah it
just got like here's the thing is is
that I don't want to say it does in this
way so I'm not gonna teach when I see
some Asian comics there is a about my
body
sometimes reacts in a very negative kind
of a way when they're to when I don't
when they're to Fabi or stereotypical I
just end up closing down and I begin
hating them hate yeah yeah I do because
at the end of the day Tamiya Otsuki came
up to me you know she was like one of
the first she was very Fabi but to my
yard Suki used to date Sam Kinison she
she were kimono on stages of pre-market
show and she said to me she goes um
Bobby make sure that you make us look
good don't make us look bad I go what do
you mean it's just there are ways to
tell your job in a positive light right
for Asians and I go oh so I just start
started thinking in that way because I
never wanted to be Bobby for some reason
I don't think I am naturally if I was
born pretty cool
what why do you keep saying that word
Bobby like what is the [ __ ] fob until
like I don't understand what Fabi is to
you I'll tell you what it's okay
function you know Fung Shui actually I
love Harry dead I know because he to me
Fung what's his name you know what a fun
way yeah tchau tchau tchau tchau chinks
yeah yeah there's this asian guy in that
the commissioning function
yeah okay he has a thick accent yeah
he's got tattoos he's not far be even
though he's not american-born even
though he has an
accent there's just something like
Yakuza about him that's cool and his
accent keeps getting better and better
like every time I see you morning that
is true right before Isabella I told him
that he's a Bobby now he's you can see
Bobby yeah yeah but he's cool he so
that's not what I mean if somebody was
born in Asia or here when I say Fabi it
means that they just seems so
traditionally Asian and it's okay for
the world it's great for the world
because we need them but in terms of
representing us on television and stuff
I don't like it because I grew up with
stereotypes you know so it's like you
know I wasn't good at grades and then
you know your teacher would look at
you're like this is kind of [ __ ] no
I'm just a human being who I don't want
to do it I smoke pot and I'm a [ __ ]
it but they thought because of these
stereotypes that I would be able to kill
it
Yeah right and I can't I just took this
school like people trust the next to you
yeah they'll try to cheat off me and
then we all get out yeah so it's like
you know I I'm just not traditional so I
when I see guys like you that's a little
like when you when he first my first met
you I'm like what the [ __ ] is this yeah
I like it it's different
Peter you know he's gay and he just
talks about calm you mean and I go I
like it just talk about black calm and I
love it
you know when I run into like even like
you know here's a great example of it
we've had what's her name on the show
Aquafina she's he's like that in that
way of just kind of being American
almost and American and a 100% but and
just in terms of just reflecting a side
of you know culture that I like seeing
is basically giving the best compliment
why you seem so disappointed right thank
you for digging so deep no I appreciate
that I appreciate good I think most
Asians are traditionally they go towards
the Caucasian you know yeah and they
usually brought up around Caucasian
Asian people they get there to get their
little dry cleaners their little stores
and they you work hard and they just
move to the suburbs yeah you know my
family was so cheap they're like we're
gonna have three families in a home and
just gonna stay in the hood yeah was
that like we're poor it's just they're
just so cheap North Korean they just my
mom wears $5.00 shirts they eat nothing
but like well yo your mom's from there
then too she has a kid Raja I think she
was oh she grew up in China my father
escaped and then she grew up in China so
that's where the chain came from then
yeah I think so
right it's not korean/chang yeah I know
so is that what you had in common with
your wife when you guys first met like
hey both our families are forum area
dating out for North Koreans you get one
match the only one in Virginia just just
kind of met you know I saw her act
that's how we met was uh we had mutual
friends getting back home she's from DC
too we have mutual friends I saw her she
commented on one of my friends things
and I just start DMing her is the it
didn't work she ignored it she thought
about month later she hit she misses me
back two weeks later she flew out and uh
oh yeah it must later were engaged when
we decide we decide is that what it is
you [ __ ] take forever though
maybe not you him well that's not what I
mean I've already decided at night in
general you know when a girl is like you
know what I'm gonna give this guy a shot
we really go for it and I did that with
you I'm gonna give this one a shot and
now we're four years deep [ __ ] I mean
what do you what do you do what do you
[ __ ] yappin about right nothing you're
right we have five animals we have five
[ __ ] animals man oh my god today when
I met you did I know her I think you met
her
little bit after right cuz you told me
about her after a little bit you're very
excited he was so excited there we go
and now right now you just went up on my
[ __ ] books bro great
I was excited I'm still excited about
her I was just in the San Jose thank you
for coming out everyone
by the way it was a wonderful weekend
and people want Tiger belly their live
live yeah that's what people were saying
can you bring the podcasts out there I
think that that would be fill that room
though that's a big theater I think we
could do one day of it yeah if we just
plug the [ __ ] out of it we promote San
Francisco - we can't do San Francisco
and San Jose it's too close no I'm
saying we know we do one just in San
Jose but we promoted in San Francisco
people can drive an hour yeah it's not
that much an hour for us LA it's not
that much tell them - anywhere else in
the United States they're like [ __ ] no
yeah but we